sometimes it's the smallest things I can
have the biggest form of that one it's a
smallest thing just saying alhamdulillah
just saying whatever it may be praying
in places that people can see us also
has an effect on them it pulls them
towards if there's a magnetic force in
the purity of prayer there's a magnetic
force in the purity of Quran there's a
magnetic force in the purity of Allah
right and Allah Allah is pure so
whenever we have any of those pure
elements within us it doesn't attract
people to us because of our
personalities we're all dull people it
attracts people to us because of that
Purity and if we lose that Purity then
we have nothing left right then the
honor of a Believer is dependent and
contingent upon Him honoring his
religion